justement la page la prestation
d'allocations versées pour aux parents
d'enfants de moins de 3 ans alors on
nous a entendus dans l'hémicycle du
sénat cette semaine nous vous y avait eu
un échange assez musclé avec le vif avec
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn donc
le projet du gouvernement c'est de
baisser cette allocation sans rentrer
dans les détails en tout cas il se il
dit vouloir faire une mesure de
simplification qui va être bonne pour
les familles vous c'est pas du tout
votre avis qu'est ce que vous reprochez
au gouvernement vous qui avait été
ministre
la page c'était cette prestation est
versée déjà sous conditions de
ressources pour les familles qui ont
trente mille euros de revenus annuels
le gouvernement baisse le plafond à 26
mille euros ça veut dire que 150 mille
familles qui gagnent entre 26 mille
euros et 30 mille euros c'est pas quand
même des gens on peut parler de montrer
du doigt comme étant les profiteurs de
la société française vont perdre et fall
alpha des familles riches vont perdre
cette allocation
et puis une autre mesure qui est un
alignement de prestation qui va faire
baisser la prestation de 15 euros
donc ça c'est ouf j'ai dit à la ministre
ce qui par ailleurs à des mesures que je
soutiens en particulier en faveur des
familles monoparentales des mesures
nouvelles ce que j'ai dit à la ministre
c'est que d'abord si elle pouvait faire
des mesures nouvelles c'était parce que
nous nous avions fait des économies et
ramener le budget de la caisse
d'allocations familiales prestation
familiale à l' équilibre ce qui lui
permet de poursuivre ce que j'avais déjà
engagées c'est à dire une réelle
réajustement d'un petit fais mien en
faveur des familles monoparentales et
que par ailleurs les économies que nous
avions fait par la modulation est prêtre
quand les choses un peu crûment
on a fait plusieurs du travail quand on
a fait la modulation des locaux dont
vous êtes énervé
donc je me suis pas énervé j'étais très
calme j'ai simplement dit que cette
mesure ne me paraissait pas nécessaire
qu'elle était injuste et que ce n'était
pas elle n'était pas utile ni
budgétairement ni socialement et je lui
ai demandé pourquoi elle n'avait pas
choisi d'aligner sur le plafond le plus
élevé est pourquoi il choisissait de
faire sortir 150 mille familles il
n'était pas nécessaire de faire des
nouvelles économies dans la branche
famille cette année